we are being told more and more that
we're not allowed to say certain things
we're not allowed to question
the woke people in any way the dominant
woke regime
and one idaho police officer just got in
trouble for doing just that
this would be nate sylvester nate
sylvester resident of twin falls idaho
works as a deputy marshal
for the marshal's office in bellevue
idaho he's got 13 years of law
enforcement experience
he has a bs in criminal justice so he's
got a lot of experience been on the job
for a long time and
a few weeks ago when lebron james came
out
and doxxed or sort of doxed
that police officer who saved a life
in the killing of makia bryant who went
out there was a
a black girl about to stab another black
girl and then this white cop
shot the assailant he was then pilloried
he was
castigated and lebron james posted a
picture of him he said you're next you
know we're coming for you
and so uh nate sylvester goes out and
makes a tick-tock video
joking about this sort of thing and uh
was suspended from the force he was
suspended for this not allowed in any
way to question it
take a listen to the video and see if
you believe that officer
sylvester should have been suspended
seen at that disturbance call can you
have lebron call myself one right away
please thank you
sir excuse me can you put the knife down
please sir no no no
no sir put the don't stab it one second
lebron hey yeah it's me again listen i
got two guys fighting over here and one
of them's got a knife he wants to stab
the other guy
what do you think i should do why does
it matter what the race is
all right well they're both black okay
but he's trying to stab the other guy
deadly force is totally justified
uh-huh i see
okay okay so you don't care if a black
person kills another black person but
you do care
if a white cop kills a black person even
if he's doing it to save
the life of another black person i mean
it doesn't make a lot of sense but
then again you are really good at
basketball so i guess i'll take your
word for it
all right okay thanks lbj all right yeah
michael jordan's the goat
what nothing i gotta go hey guys sorry
you're on your own
so very well executed by the way i have
to say
a lot of these tick tock videos can be a
little little cringe but
but this one really i think got the
point and yet
he was still suspended luckily we are
joined right now by
nate sylvester nate thank you so much
for being here
yeah thanks for having me michael so i i
was really
outraged and frustrated when you were
suspended for this
i thought finally someone is just
pointing out a little bit of common
sense here
someone is finally sticking up for the
cops in these cases
where some of the most radical and
ignorant people in the country
are constantly pillaring them these guys
who are just
you know keeping people safe who are
enforcing the rule of law
and and you got suspended where does
that stand
now well right now i'm back to work
uh there is a little strained
relationship
between me and the and the mayor and the
city council but
uh so far i still have a job very
pleased to hear that
you know too often in these cases you'll
see the political considerations come
over
and you know someone will lose their job
for saying something that is impolitic
or politically
incorrect did i also read correctly that
you have received a book deal over this
incident
uh that's correct uh in the aftermath of
all of that
uh i was contacted by d'angelo
publications
uh they saw the tick tock uh they saw
the news reports and the the media
attention that i was getting
and looked into my history a little bit
and reached out to me and
i met with the president of that company
and we drew up a contract and off we
went
i'm so pleased to hear that because
obviously
you know what you're talking about
you've got a lot of experience here on
this particular issue
and this is a topic this issue of law
enforcement police brutality
the criminal justice system in america
where it seems we only ever hear
from one side we only ever hear from the
radicals who want to dismantle the
system
and we're never permitted to hear the
other side of the argument so
i know it's the worst thing to ask an
author is how's the book going and
what are you going to write about but
right now whether it's in the book or
whether it's just
in an interview or two what is your
message for people on this topic where
there's so much noise on the other side
well the message is i guess we need to
start hearing the noise
on the other side of this yeah it's been
my experience
since uh you know the tick tock went
viral i've
received tens of thousands of emails and
messages and phone calls and letters
and donations uh of people in support of
me and of law enforcement in general and
that's what i want
officers all across the nation to know
and experience
i think if they can experience that
they'll be able to see the light at the
end of this
anti-police rhetoric tunnel uh and
and have a little more optimism when
they go into their jobs
because right now i think it's looking
very uh grim
for a lot of officers especially in
those bigger urban areas where they
don't
see that support they don't hear about
it uh and that's
a part of what my book will be about is
the support that i've received and that
i want other officers to experience well
this is a phenomenon you see in
especially in new york but in
a lot of big cities people are just
leaving the force a lot of officers
think
look not only is it not worth it forget
about i mean to be a cop
is to make a sacrifice and you put
yourself in dangerous situations
and it's not as though you become a
zillionaire doing it but you're you're
protecting people you're protecting the
community you're defending the rule of
law
but now if you add on to that that your
life will be
absolutely destroyed if some politically
correct radicals get
get a hold of of any sort of situation
you're involved in
i see why people are retiring early why
people are not joining the force
so what happens you know if we lose a
significant portion of our cops
then what happens to these communities
well they they weather and die
i don't understand how people don't see
that if you don't have a stable police
force in your community
how it's going to thrive it's just
simply not the case
you know people don't want to visit or
live in a community uh where they have
to be in fear for their lives or
you know fear of losing their property
on a daily basis and that's what the
police officers do
is they they keep that kind of activity
at bay or at least uh to a to a minimum
um and i'm for the life of me i can't
figure out why
people don't understand that this whole
defund the police
uh sentiment has has
it seems to have grown in popularity
recently
but i don't think that people are really
looking forward to anticipate the
consequences
of actually defunding police departments
so
i want to focus in on on one of the
funniest lines in the video i guess
there were several but and one of them
where you say okay so
you know this person's about to stab the
other person
um the use of deadly force is definitely
justified and by the way just so you
know lebron
the assailant and the potential victim
are both black
so is that okay can i defend the one
black person from the other black person
i'm white so i know
that's going to complicate it in your
kind of racial politics oh no i'm not
allowed to okay well never mind
and the joke gets to a real phenomenon
here which is that
the the victims in that will
now increase because cops are leaving
these places the police departments
are being defunded the victims are going
to be disproportionately
black so what is it do you have do you
have an explanation here on why
these radical activists speaking under
the banner of black lives matter
would advocate for a policy that will
result
in the injury and deaths of more black
people
well and i think that's the
million-dollar dollar question is what
what exactly are we supposed to do
um this officer in columbus ohio officer
reardon like you mentioned saved the
life
of a young black girl so if if that
wasn't
justified or if that was wrong in the
eyes of people like lebron james and
you know the woke crowd then what
exactly is the alternative
because from my point of view as an
experienced police officer there was
none
that officer did the only thing that he
could do in that situation
to save a life and one of the things
that people don't actually
think about too often is that what what
would have happened
had that officer failed to act or chose
not to act
i mean if he could have anticipated what
would have happened
in the in the aftermath of that and
hesitated even for a second
and that young girl lost her life
because she was being stabbed to death
that officer would face probably some
criminal charges definitely some
uh some civil uh repercussions
uh he could have faced numerous policy
violations for
uh the dereliction of duty or cowardice
or whatever the case is
uh so what i i have yet to hear what
exactly the
alternative is or what what we're
supposed to do uh
in lieu of actually doing our jobs and
doing what we're justified in doing and
officer reardon's case that was to
shoot the person with a knife who was
ready to stab another person
it seems to me this is a heads i win
tails you lose sort of situation i
i think you're totally right had the
video come out of him hesitating then
he would have been called a racist and
an idiot and a coward
of because he didn't because he didn't
shoot the girl right the girl that was
holding the knife
i i do wonder if a lot of this is
because
the the left views the country as
hopelessly
unjust bigoted evil white supremacist
you know whatever
slogan is being used as the synonym here
and
the reason that the police officers come
under fire
is because they are the physical
representation of the whole system
right we have this whole system of
justice and law in this country
and that's all just kind of floating in
outer space right i mean that's those
are all just
ideas that's all just the the the words
of the constitution and of our legal
code
but the cops are the ones who are
enforcing the law that's why that's why
they are law enforcement
and so i wonder if the attacks on on the
police officers
actually have nothing to do with the
police officers themselves
and they're really just attacking them
as the symbol of the whole system
right and they're they're they're being
targeted as as a group
um which is what we see other groups of
people actually complaining about but
it's happening to police officers as
well and
actually and so in my book never off
duty um i address
that um the whole the idea that
police officers are systemically racist
and every one of them is inherently
corrupt simply because of their calling
to law enforcement to be a police
officer when in fact
police officers are individuals there's
someone behind that badge
who is a good decent person for the most
part i mean of the 800
000 police officers we have in the
country the majority of them are good
honest people who
um have proven that they are ethical and
scrupulous
and uh are capable of doing police work
right
you know i have a number of friends who
are police officers or who have been
police officers in the past
and you know they've got different
political parties and things like that
but they tend to be
basically ordinary good normal
sane americans who you know salute the
american flag
and have a good stable sort of life
however we've seen this increasingly now
because of the you i don't know if you
saw the woke
us army ad the woke cia ad
police departments now very often
sucking up to left-wing organizations
because of political pressures and i it
does occur to me that if the
if the radicals take over the
establishment the institutions
then eventually even something like law
enforcement is going to go woke
as well have you seen this at all on the
ground and have you heard about this
sort of fear
from fellow officers or people who are
thinking about joining the force
i haven't seen it personally um and that
hasn't been a topic of conversation
um at least not uh where i work with the
way they treated me with the suspension
and wanting to remove my tick tocks from
social media
um now it's it's become
it's become this idea that if you
support police officers then you're
aggressive and you're racist
um and you're corrupt um right but if
you know
yeah if you show uh your support for for
groups like blm and you buy into this
woke ideology and you're anti-police
well that means you're woke and some
you've somehow
transcended uh the rest of royal people
well you can
you can support the police in particular
nate sylvester by going out and getting
that book ordering that book never off
duty we're up against a wall so i got to
go
so great to speak with you thank you so
much